at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by four Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it if too much of a headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio
lecture comes in single serving packets
which are perfect for travel and in fact
I'm about to leave the country right now
and I have a packet in front of me
that's just gonna sit in the end of my
carry-on bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily
here's some recommended copy that they
put in the read so I'm gonna read it and
I'll give you my take quote a warning
for those in the experimental mindset
reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine so
if the bitterness is too much I
recommend trying it with honey
or nutmilk such as almond milk and quote
so I'm gonna say no you should suck it
up and you should drink the tea because
it's not that bitter and maybe you
should take the advice of all Chinese
people when they're criticizing young
uns when they say boo and I'm sure
they're cool which means you're not able
to eat bitterness bitter is in many
cases an indication of things that help
liver detoxification and so on not
saying that's the case here but I've
tested this ratio lecture on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and no don't put it in honey or a nut
milk or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like poo air that kind of stuff
that type of tea you're gonna dig it so
just try it okay
back at you then my read if you'd like
to naturally improve your sleep both on
set and quality I think naturally you
might just enjoy this ratio lecture
without any sweeteners it has organic
reishi extract organic fueled mint
extract organic rosehips extract organic
Tulsi extract and that's it no fancy
stuff no artificial whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to four
sigma tech comm forward slash ferrous
and get 20% off this special batch I
don't know if they're gonna be making
much more of this since it was made
specifically for you guys so do me a
favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for Sikkim
addict that's fo you are SI GMA TI c
calm /e Ferriss f e RR ISS and get 20%
off the special batch and you must use
the code Ferriss to receive your
discount fer our ISS so again go to 4
Sigma to comm forward slash Ferriss and
then use code Ferriss for 20% off of
this rare exclusive limited run of
reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime
routines without any sweeteners enjoy
hello my sexy little minx is this is
timber's and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show where it is my
job
generally speaking to deconstruct
world-class performers of different
types to tease out the habits routines
favorite books and so on that you can
use this episode I am going to showcase
one of my recent favorite books and by
recent I say in the last few years there
are not many books that I highlight
something within nearly every page much
less than printing out those highlights
putting them together with a binder clip
and carrying around at various points to
review and to journal on and so forth
and so on that book that I'm referring
to is essentialism subtitle the
disciplined pursuit of less it is a
fantastic book I was very impressed the
first time I read it I've been
continually impressed when I've reread
it it's had an impact in how I approach
various types of problems and
opportunities so I want to share two
chapters from that book with you read by
the author Greg McEwan Gregory McEwen on
Twitter let me spell that for you it's a
little tricky for most Yanks Gregory
McEwen MC ke o WN also Gregory McEwan
dot-com and I'm lying
it is not Gregory BQ and calm it's Greg
McEwan calm so you can figure it out
there aren't too many Gregor Gregory the
Cubans running around associated with
essentialism the two chapters that I'm
going to share are related to how to say
no gracefully and how to uncommit
because I think it is very easy to
listen to podcasts with success stories
and tactics and habits and to create an
ever-growing or never-ending to-do list
you might have 73 different things on
the draft version of your morning
routine and that is stressful so I would
like to help you
visa V Greg and his book essentialism
- maybe shorten your to-do-list
and lengthen your not to do list so
again these two chapters are from
essentialism subtitle the discipline
pursuit of less maybe sometime I will
have Greg on the podcast discussed
further but this episode is experimental
I am considering showcasing books not
brand new books so publishers who are
listening do not hammer we with a
thousand pitches they're not going to
get in will not be on but books that
were published at least a few years ago
showcasing books that I have read at
least two times and this is one of them
so let me know if you like it and
without further ado how to say no
gracefully how to uncommit by Greg
McEwan chapter 11 dare the power of a
graceful no courage is grace under
pressure
Ernest Hemingway the write no spoken at
the right time can change the course of
history in just one example of many Rosa
Parks quiet but resolute refusal to give
up her seat on a segregated Montgomery
bus at exactly the right moment
coalesced into forces that propelled the
civil rights movement as parks recalls
when the bus driver saw me still sitting
he asked if I was going to stand up and
I said no I'm not contrary to popular
belief her courageous no did not grow
out of a particularly assertive tendency
or personality in general in fact when
she was made a secretary to the
president of the Montgomery chapter of
the n-double a-c-p she explained I was
the only woman there and they needed a
secretary and I was too timid to say no
rather her decision on the bus grew out
of a deep conviction about what
deliberate choice she wanted to make in
that moment when the bus driver ordered
her out of her seat she said I felt a
determination cover my body like a quilt
on a winter night she did not know how
her decision would spark a movement with
reverberations around the world but she
did know her own mind
she knew even as she was being arrested
that it was the very last time that I
would ever ride in humiliation of this
kind avoiding that humiliation was worth
the risk of incarceration indeed to her
it was essential it is true that we are
hopefully unlikely to find ourselves
facing a situation like the one faced by
Rosa Parks yet we can be inspired by her
we can think of her when we need the
courage to dare to say no we can
remember her strength of conviction when
we need to stand our ground in the face
of social pressure to capitulate to the
nonessential have you ever felt a
tension between what you felt was right
and what someone was pressuring you to
do have you ever felt the conflict
between your internal conviction and an
external action have you ever said yes
when you meant no simply to avoid
conflict or friction have you ever felt
too scared or timid to turn down an
invitation or request from a boss
colleague friend neighbor or family
member for fear of disappointing them if
you have you're not alone navigating
these moments with courage and grace is
one of the most important skills to
master in becoming an essentialist and
one of the hardest I did not set out to
write a chapter about courage but the
deeper I've looked at the subject of
essentialism the more clearly I have
seen courage as key to the process of
elimination without courage the
disciplined pursuit of less is just lip
service it is just the stuff of one more
dinner party conversation it is skin
deep anyone can talk about the
importance of focusing on the things
that matter most and many people do but
to see people who dare to live it is
rare I say this without judgment we have
good reasons to fear saying no we worry
we'll miss out on a great opportunity
we're scared of rocking the boat
stirring things up burning bridges we
can't bear the thought of disappointing
someone we respect and like none of this
makes us a bad person it's a natural
part of being human
yet as hard as it can be to say no to
someone failing to do so can cause us to
miss out on something far more important
a woman named Cynthia once told me a
story about the time her father had made
plans to take her on a night out in San
Francisco
twelve-year-old Cynthia and her father
had been planning the date for months
they had a whole itinerary planned down
to the minute she would attend the last
hour of his presentation and then meet
him at the back of the room at about
4:30 and leave quickly before everyone
tried to talk to him they would catch a
trolley car to Chinatown eat Chinese
food their favorite shop for a souvenir
see the sights for a while and then
catch a flick I said I'd like to say
then they would grab a taxi back to the
hotel jump in the pool for a quick swim
her dad was famous for sneaking in when
the pool was closed order a hot fudge
sundae from room service and watched The
Late Late Show they discussed the
details over and over before they left
the anticipation was part of the whole
experience this was all going according
to plan until as her father was leaving
the Convention Center he ran into an old
college friend and business associate it
had been years since they had seen each
other and Cynthia watched as they
embraced enthusiastically his friends
said in effect I am so glad you were
doing some work with our company now
when Lois and I heard about it we
thought it would be perfect we want to
invite you and of course Cynthia to get
a spectacular seafood dinner down at the
wharf
Cynthia's father responded Bob it's so
great to see you dinner at the wharf
sounds great
Cynthia was crestfallen her daydreams of
trolley rides and ice-cream sundaes
evaporated in an instant plus she hated
seafood and she could just imagine how
bored she would be listening to the
adults talk all night but then her
father continued but not tonight
Cynthia and I have a special date plan
don't we he winked at Cynthia and
grabbed her hand and they ran out of the
door and continued with what was an
unforgettable night in San Francisco
as it happens Cynthia's father was the
management thinker stephen r.covey
author of the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People who had passed away
only weeks before Cynthia told me this
story so it was with deep emotion she
recalled that evening in San Francisco
his simple decision bonded him to me
forever because I knew what mattered
most to him was me she said stephen
r.covey one of the most respected and
widely read business thinkers of his
generation was an essentialist not only
did he routinely teach essentialist
principles like the main thing is to
keep the main thing the main thing two
important leaders and heads of state
around the world he lived them and in
this moment of living them with his
daughter he made a memory that literally
outlasted his lifetime seeing with some
perspective his decision seems obvious
but many in his shoes would have
accepted the friends invitation for fear
of seeming rude or ungrateful or passing
up a rare opportunity to dine with an
old friend so why is it so hard in the
moment to dare to choose what is
essential / what is non-essential one
simple answer is we are unclear about
what is essential when this happens we
become defenseless on the other hand
when we have strong internal parity it
is almost as if we have a force field
protecting us from the non-essentials
coming at us from all directions with
Rosa it was a deep moral clarity that
gave her unusual courage of conviction
with Stephen it was the clarity of his
vision for the evening with his loving
daughter in virtually every instance
clarity about what is essential fuels us
with the strength to say no to the
non-essentials essentially awkward a
second reason why it is hard to choose
what is essential in the moment is as
simple as an innate fear of social
awkwardness the fact is we as humans are
wired to want to get along with others
after all thousands of years ago when we
all lived in tribes of hunter-gatherers
our survival depended on it and while
conforming to what people in a group
expected us what psychologists call
normative conformity is no longer a
matter of life and death that is
is still deeply ingrained in us this is
why whether it's an old friend who
invites you to dinner or a boss who asks
you to take on an important high-profile
project or a neighbor who begs you to
help with the PTA bake sale the very
thought of saying no literally brings us
physical discomfort we feel guilty we
don't want to let someone down we are
worried about damaging the relationship
but these emotions muddle our clarity
they distract us from the reality of the
fact that either we can say no and
regret it for a few minutes or we can
say yes and regret it for days weeks
months or even years the only way out of
this trap is to learn to say no firmly
resolutely and yet gracefully because
once we do we find not only that our
fears of disappointing or angering
others were exaggerated but the people
actually respect us more since becoming
an essentialist I have found it almost
universally true that people respect and
admire those with the courage of
conviction to say no Peter Drucker in my
view the father of modern management
thinking was also a master of the art of
the graceful know when Mihai
Csikszentmihalyi the Hungarian professor
most well known for his work on flow
reached out to interview a series of
creative individuals for a book he was
writing on creativity
Drucker's response was interesting
enough to me high that he quoted it
verbatim I am greatly honored and
flattered by your kind letter of
February 14th for I have admired you and
your work for many years and I've
learned much from it but my dear
professor exempt me high I am afraid I
have to disappoint you I could not
possibly answer your questions I am told
I am creative I don't know what that
means I just keep on plodding I hope you
will not think me presumptuous or rude
if I say that one of the secrets of
productivity in which I believed whereas
I do not believe in creativity is to
have a very big waste paper basket to
take care of all invitations such as
yours productivity in my experience
consists of not doing anything that
helps the work
of other people but to spend all one's
time on the work the good Lord has
fitted one to do and to do well
a true essentialist Peter Drucker
believed that people are effective
because they say no non-essential ist's
say yes because of feelings of social
awkwardness and pressure they say yes
automatically without thinking often in
pursuit of the rush one gets from having
please someone
but essentialist know that after the
rush comes the pang of regret they know
they will soon feel bullied and
resentful both at the other person and
at themselves eventually they will wake
up to the unpleasant reality that
something more important must now be
sacrificed to accommodate this new
commitment of course the point is not to
say no to all requests the point is to
say no to the non-essential so we can
say yes to the things that really matter
it is to say no frequently and
gracefully to everything but what is
truly vital a non essentialist avoid
saying no to avoid feeling social
awkwardness and pressure an essentialist
dares to say no firmly resolutely and
gracefully a non-essential ist's A's yes
to everything an essentialist says yes
only to the things that really matter so
how do we learn to say no gracefully
below our general guidelines followed by
a number of specific scripts for
delivering the graceful mo separate the
decision from the relationship when
people ask us to do something we can
confuse the request with our
relationship with them sometimes they
seem so interconnected we forget that
denying the request is not the same as
denying for person only once we separate
the decision from the relationship can
we make a clear decision and then
separately find the courage and
compassion to communicate it saying no
gracefully doesn't have to mean using
the word no essentialists choose no more
and then they say no there may be a time
when the most graceful way to say no is
to simply say a blunt no but whether
it's I am flattered that you thought of
me but I'm afraid I don't have the
bandwidth or I would very much like to
but I'm over committed there are a
variety of ways of refusing someone
clearly and politely without actually
using the word no later in the chapter
you'll find more examples of ways to
gracefully word your no focus on the
trade-off the more we think about what
we are giving up when we say yes to
someone the easier it is to say no if we
have no clear sense of the opportunity
cost in other words the value of what we
are giving up then it is especially easy
to fall into the non-essential trap of
telling ourselves we can get it all done
we can't a graceful no grows out of a
clear but unstated calculation of the
trade-off remind yourself that everyone
is selling something this doesn't mean
you have to be cynical about people I
don't mean to imply people shouldn't be
trusted I'm simply saying everyone is
selling something an idea a viewpoint an
opinion in exchange for your time simply
being aware of what is being sold allows
us to be more deliberate in deciding
whether we want to buy it make your
peace with the fact that saying no often
requires trading popularity for respect
when you say no there is usually a
short-term impact on the relationship
after all when someone asks for
something and doesn't get it his or her
immediate reaction may be annoyance or
disappointment or even anger this
downside is clear the potential upside
however is less obvious when the initial
annoyance or disappointment or anger
wears off the respect kicks in when we
push back effectively it shows people
that our time is highly valuable it
distinguishes the professional from the
amateur a case in point is the time the
graphic designer Paul Rand had the guts
to say no to Steve Jobs
when Jobs was looking for a logo for the
company next he asked Rand whose work
included the logos for IBM ups Enron
Westinghouse and ABC to come up with a
few options but ran didn't want to come
up with a few options he wanted to
design just one option Saran said no I
will solve your problem for you and you
will pay me and you don't have to use
the solution if you want options go talk
to other people but I will solve the
problem the best way I know how and do
you use it or not that's up to you not
surprisingly Rand solved the problem and
created the dual logo Jobs wanted but
the real lesson here is the effect rands
pushback had on jobs who later said a
Rand he is one of the most professional
people I have ever worked with in the
sense that he had thought through all of
the formal relationship between a client
and a professional such as himself ran
took a risk when he said no he bet a
short term popularity loss for a
long-term gain in respect and it paid
off essentialists except they cannot be
popular with everyone all of the time
yes
saying no respectfully reasonably and
gracefully can come at a short-term
social cost but part of living the way
of the essentialist is realizing respect
is far more valuable than popularity in
the long run remember that a clear no
can be more graceful than a vague or
non-committal yes as anyone who has ever
been on the receiving end of this
situation knows it clear I am going to
pass on this is far better than not
getting back to someone or stringing
them along with some non-committal
answer like I will try to make this work
or I might be able to when you know you
can't being vague is not the same as
being graceful and delaying the eventual
no will only make it that much harder
and the recipient that much more
resentful the no repertoire remember
essentialists don't say no just
occasionally it is a part of their
regular repertoire
consistently say no with grace then it
helps to have a variety of responses to
call upon following our eight responses
you can put in your no repertoire
one the awkward pause instead of being
controlled by the threat of an awkward
silence own it use it as a tool when a
request comes to you obviously this
works only in person just pause for a
moment count to three before delivering
your verdict or if you get a bit more
bold simply wait for the other person to
fill the void to the soft no or the no
but I recently received an email
inviting me to coffee I replied I am
consumed with writing my book right now
smiley face but I would love to get
together once the book is finished let
me know if we can get together towards
the end of the summer email is also a
good way to start practicing saying no
but because it gives you the chance to
draft and redraft your no to make it as
graceful as possible plus many people
find that the distance of email reduces
the fear of awkwardness 3 let me check
my calendar and get back to you one
leader I know found her time being
hijacked by other people all day a
classic non essential esteem as capable
and smart and unable to say no and as a
result she soon became a go-to person
people would run up to her and say could
you help with X project meaning to be a
good citizen she said yes but soon she
felt burdened with all of these
different agendas things changed for her
when she learned to use a new phrase let
me check my calendar and get back to you
it gave her the time to pause and
reflect and ultimately reply that she
was regretfully unavailable it enabled
her to take back control of her own
decisions rather than be rushed into a
yes when she was asked for use email
bounce backs it is totally natural and
expected to get an auto response when
someone is traveling or out of the
office really this is the most socially
we'll know there is people aren't saying
they don't want to reply to your email
they're just saying they can't get back
to you for a period of time so why limit
these two vacations and holidays when I
was writing this book I set an email
bounced back with the subject line in
monk mode the email said dear friends
I'm currently working on a new book
which has put enormous burdens on my
time unfortunately I am unable to
respond in the manner I would like for
this I apologize
Greg and guess what people seem to adapt
to my temporary absence and
non-responsiveness just fine five say
yes what should I do prioritize saying
no to a senior leader at work is almost
unthinkable even laughable for many
people however when saying yes is going
to compromise your ability to make the
highest level of contribution to your
work it is also your obligation in this
case it is not only reasonable to say no
it is essential one effective way to do
that is to remind your superiors what
you would be neglecting if you said yes
and force them to grapple with the
trade-off for example if your manager
comes to you and asks you to do X you
can respond with yes I'm happy to make
this the priority which of these other
projects should I deep Rio ties to pay
attention to this new project or simply
say I would want to do a great job and
given my other commitments I wouldn't be
able to do a job I was proud of if I
took this on I know a leader who
received this response from a
subordinate there was no way he wanted
to be responsible for disrupting this
productive and organized employee so he
took the non-essential work project back
and gave it to someone else who was less
organized
6 say it with humor I recently was asked
by a friend to join him in training for
a marathon my response was simple nope
he laughed a little and said are you
practice what you preach just goes to
show how useful it is to have a
reputation as an essentialist
seven use the words you are welcome to X
I am willing to why for example you are
welcome to borrow my car I'm willing to
make sure the keys are here for you buy
this you are also saying I won't be able
to drive you you are saying what you
will not do but you are couching it in
terms of what you are willing to do this
is a particularly good way to navigate a
request you would like to support
somewhat but cannot throw your full
weight behind I particularly like this
construct because it also expresses a
respect for the other person's ability
to choose as well as your own it reminds
both parties of the choices they have
eight I can't do it but X might be
interested it is tempting to think that
our help is uniquely invaluable but
often people requesting something don't
really care if we are the ones who help
them as long as they get the help
Kaye krill the CEO of an Inc aka Ann
Taylor and loft women's clothing
retailers used to have a terrible time
saying no to social invitations as a
result she would end up at networking
event she had no interest in attending
she would find herself going to office
parties and regretting at the moment she
got there then one day one of her
mentors came to her and told her that
she had to learn to jettison the people
and things of her life that just didn't
matter and that doing so would allow her
to put a hundred percent of her energy
into the things that had meaning for her
that advice liberated her now she is
able to pick and choose with practice
politely declining an invitation has
become easy for her Tay explains I say
no very easily because I know what is
important to me I only wish that I
learned how to do that earlier in my
life saying though is its own leadership
capability it is not just a peripheral
skill as with any ability we start with
limited experience we are novices at
know then we learn a couple of basic
techniques we make mistakes
we learn from them we develop more
skills we keep practicing after a while
we have a whole repertoire available at
our disposal and in time we have gained
mastery of a type of social art form we
can handle almost any request from
almost anybody with grace and dignity
Tom Friel the former CEO of Heidrick &
Struggles once said to me we need to
learn the slow yes and the quick no
chapter 12 uncommit win big by cutting
your losses half of the troubles of this
life can be traced to saying yes too
quickly and not saying no soon enough
Josh billings by any estimation the
Concorde jet was a striking achievement
in aeronautical engineering aboard this
passenger plane you could fly from
London to New York in as little as two
hours 52 minutes and 59 seconds that's
less than half the time of a traditional
plane making the concorde the fastest
passenger plane in the world
unfortunately it was also an
extraordinary financial failure of
course many great ideas innovations and
products are but what made this one
different was that it consistently lost
money for more than four decades yet
each time it went over-budget the French
and British governments poured more and
more money in they did this even knowing
that the chance of recouping their
continued investments let alone the
original expenditures were miniscule
with the planes limited seating few
orders coming in and a high cost of
production it was clear that even with
exaggerated estimates the project would
never be profitable indeed when the
British Cabinet Papers were released
under the 30-year rule they revealed
that government ministers at the time
knew the investment could not stand on
normal economic grounds why would
intelligent capable British and French
government officials continue to invest
what was clearly a losing proposition
for so long one reason is a very common
psychological phenomenon called sunk
cost bias sunk cost bias is the tendency
to continue to invest time money or
energy into something we know is a
losing proposition simply because we
have already incurred or sunk a cost
that cannot be recouped but of course
this can easily become a vicious cycle
the more we invest the more determined
we become to see it through and see our
investment payoff the more we invest in
something the harder it is to let go the
sunk costs for developing and building
the concorde were around 1 billion
dollars yet the more money the British
and French governments poured into it
the harder it was to walk away
individuals are equally vulnerable to
sunk cost bias it explains why we'll
continue to sit through a terrible movie
because we've already paid the price of
a ticket it explains why we continue to
pour money into a home renovation that
never seems to near completion it
explains why we all continue to wait for
a bus or a subway train that never comes
instead of hailing a cab and it explains
why we invest in toxic relationships
even when our efforts only make things
worse
examples like this abound consider the
somewhat bizarre story of a man named
Henry Gribbon who recently spent his
entire life savings $2,600 in total at a
carnival game trying to win an oversized
banana the more he spent the more
determined he became to win Henry said
you just get caught up in the whole I've
got to win my money back
but it didn't turn out that way the more
he invested in trying to win this
utterly non-essential item the harder it
was for him to walk away
have you ever continued to invest time
or effort in a non-essential project
instead of cutting your losses
have you ever continued to pour money
into an investment that wasn't panning
out instead of walking away have you
ever kept plotting down a dead-end
because you could not admit I shouldn't
have pursued this direction in the first
place ever been stuck in a cycle of
throwing good money after bad a
non-essential Ascan trick free of traps
like these an essentialist has the
courage and confidence to admit his or
her mistakes and uncommit no matter the
sunk costs a non-essential estas why
stop now when I've already invested so
much in this project an essentialist
asks if I weren't already invested in
this project how much would I invest in
it now a non-essential asynch if I just
keep trying I can make this work an
essentialist thinks what else could I do
with this time or money if I pulled the
plug now a non-essential estates
admitting to mistakes an essentialist is
comfortable with cutting losses sunk
cost bias while all too common isn't the
only nom essentialist trap to watch out
for below are several other common traps
and tips for how to extricate yourself
politely gracefully and with minimal
cost avoiding commitment traps
beware of the endowment effect a sense
of ownership is a powerful thing as the
saying goes nobody in the history of the
world has washed their rental car this
is because of something called the
endowment effect our tendency to
undervalue things that aren't ours and
to overvalue things because we already
own them in one study demonstrating the
power of the endowment effect the Nobel
prize-winning researcher Daniel Kahneman
and colleagues randomly gave coffee mugs
to only half the subjects in an
experiment the first group was asked how
much they would be willing to sell their
mug for while the second group was asked
what they would be willing to pay for it
it turned out that the students who
owned the mugs refused to sell for less
than five dollars and twenty five cents
while those without the cups were
willing to pay only two dollars and 25
cents to two dollars and 75 cents
the mere fact of ownership in other
words caused the mug owners to value the
objects more highly and made them less
willing to part with them in your own
life I'm sure you can think of items
that seem to be more valuable the moment
you think about giving them away think
of a book on your shelf you haven't read
in years or a kitchen appliance still
sitting in the box or the sweater you
got from Aunt Mildred but never wore
whether or not you get any use or
enjoyment out of them subconsciously the
very fact that they are yours makes you
value them more highly than you would if
they didn't belong to you unfortunately
we have this bias when it comes to
non-essential activities as well as
belongings the project that isn't
getting anywhere at work seems that much
more critical when we're the team leader
on it the commitment to volunteer at the
local bake sale becomes harder to get
out of when we are the one who put the
fundraiser together when we feel we own
an activity it becomes harder to
uncommit nonetheless here is a useful
tip pretend you don't own it yet Tom
Stafford describes a simple antidote to
the endowment effect instead of asking
how much do I value this item we should
ask if I did not own this item how much
would I pay to obtain it we can do the
same for opportunities and commitment
don't ask how will I feel if I miss out
on this opportunity but rather if I did
not have this opportunity how much would
I be willing to sacrifice in order to
obtain it similarly we can ask if I
wasn't already involved in this project
how hard would I work to get on it get
over the fear of waste how arcs a
professor of psychology at Ohio State
University who studies judgment in
decision-making was puzzled by an enigma
why are adults so much more vulnerable
to the sunk cost bias than young
children the answer he believes a
lifetime to exposure to the don't waste
rule so that by the time we are adults
we are trained to avoid appearing
wasteful even to ourselves a
landing a project that you've invested a
lot in feels like you've wasted
everything and waste is something we're
told to avoid ark said to illustrate
this he gave the following scenario to a
group of participants assume that you
have spent a hundred dollars on a ticket
for a weekend ski trip to Michigan
several weeks later you buy a $50 ticket
for a weekend ski trip to Wisconsin you
think you will enjoy the Wisconsin ski
trip more than the Michigan ski trip as
you are putting your newly purchased
Wisconsin ticket in your wallet you
notice that the Michigan ski trip and
the Wisconsin ski trip are for the same
weekend it's too late to sell or return
either ticket
you must choose which to use when asked
which ski trip will you go on more than
half said they were opt for the more
expensive trip even though they would
enjoy it less their faulty reasoning was
that using the cheaper ticket would be
wasting more money than using the
expensive ticket it's natural not to
want to let go of what we wasted on a
bad choice but when we don't we do my
selves to keep wasting even more instead
admit failure to begin success I
remember a friend who would never stop
to ask for directions because he could
never admit he was lost so we would
waste time and energy driving around in
circles getting nowhere the epitome of a
non-essential activity only when we
admit we have made a mistake in
committing to something can we make a
mistake a part of our past when we
remain in denial on the other hand we
continue to circle pointlessly there
should be no shame in admitting to a
mistake after all we really are only
admitting that we are now wiser than we
once were stop trying to force a fit in
the movie Tootsie Dustin Hoffman plays a
struggling actor who is trying to get
work the movie begins comically with a
series of failed auditions at one he is
told
we need someone a little older at the
next he is told we're looking for
someone younger
then at the next you're the wrong height
to which she responds I can be taller
the executive responds no we're looking
for somebody shorter desperate to make
it work
Hoffman's character explains look I
don't have to be this tall see I'm
wearing lifts I can be shorter but the
executive also insists I know but we're
looking for somebody different still
persistent the would-be actor pushes
back again I can be different the point
is that we often act like Dustin
Hoffman's character by trying too hard
to be something we're not whether in our
personal or professional lives it is all
too tempting to force something that is
simply a mismatch the solution get a
neutral second opinion when we get so
emotionally hung up on trying to force
something that is not the right fit we
can often benefit from a sounding board
someone who is not emotionally involved
in the situation and unaffected by the
choice we make can give us the
permission to stop forcing something
that is clearly not working out I once
wasted months of effort trying to force
a project that just wasn't working out
looking back the more I put into it the
worse things became but my irrational
response was to invest still more I
thought I can make this work I did not
want to accept I had been wasting my
effort I finally shared my frustration
with a friend who had the advantage of
being emotionally removed from the
project someone who wasn't burdened with
the sunk costs and could evaluate my
decisions with some perspective after
listening to me he said you're not
married to this and with those simple
words I was liberated to stop investing
in a non-essential be aware of the
status quo bias the tendency to continue
doing something simply because we have
always done it is sometimes called the
status quo bias I once worked at a
company that used an employee evaluation
system that seemed to me so woeful II
outdated that I became curious about how
long it had been in place as I searched
for its creator
in the company I found that nobody up to
and including the long-standing head of
HR knew of its origin more shocking
still in the ten years she had been at
the company
nobody had once questioned the system
it's all too easy to blindly accept and
not bother to question commitments
simply because they have already been
established one cure for the status quo
bias is borrowed from the world of
accounting apply zero based budgeting
typically when accountants allocate a
budget they used last year's budget as
the baseline for the next year's
projection but with zero based budgeting
they use zero as the baseline in other
words every item in the proposed budget
must be justified from scratch
while this takes more effort it has many
advantages it efficiently allocates
resources on the basis of needs rather
than history it detects exaggerated
budget requests it draws attention to
obsolete operations and it encourages
people to be clearer in their purpose
and how their expenses align to that
project you can apply zero based
budgeting to your own endeavours instead
of trying to budget your time on the
basis of existing commitments assume
that all bets are off
all previous commitments are gone then
begin from scratch asking which you
would add today you can do this with
everything from the financial
obligations you have to projects you are
committed to even relationships you are
in every use of time energy or resources
has to justify itself anew if it no
longer fits eliminate it altogether
stop making casual commitments some
people's days are full to the brim with
soft commitments they have taken on
unintentionally through an offhand
comment or casual conversation they had
somewhere with someone you know the kind
I mean you're chatting with your
neighbour about her work on the PTA your
colleague about a new initiative she is
heading up or your friend about a new
restaurant he wants to try and before
you know it boom you're committed from
on pause before you speak it might sound
obvious but pausing for just five
seconds before offering your services
can greatly reduce the possibility of
making a commitment you'll regret before
the words that sounds great
I'd love to fly out of your mouth ask
yourself is this essential if you've
already made a casual commitment you're
regretting find a nice way to worm your
way out simply apologize and tell the
person that when you made the commitment
you didn't fully realize what it would
entail get over the fear of missing out
we've seen ample evidence in this
chapter suggesting that the majority of
us are naturally very loss averse as a
result one of the obstacles to um
committing ourselves from a present
course is the fear of missing out on
something great to fight this fear run a
reverse pilot one of the ideas that has
grown popular in business circles in
recent years is prototyping building a
prototype or large-scale model allows
companies to test run an idea or product
without making a huge investment upfront
exactly the same idea can be used in
Reverse to eliminate non essentials in a
relatively low-risk way by running what
Daniel Shapiro a director at LinkedIn
calls a reverse pilot in a reverse pilot
you test whether removing and initiative
or activity will have any negative
consequences for example when an
executive I work with took on a new
senior role in the company he inherited
a process his predecessor had gone to a
huge effort to implement a huge highly
visual report on a myriad of subjects
produced for the other executives each
week it consumed enormous energy from
his team and he hypothesized that it was
not adding a great deal of value to the
company said to test his hypothesis he
ran a reverse pilot he simply stopped
publishing the report and waited to see
what the response would be what he found
was that no one seemed to miss it after
several weeks nobody had even mentioned
the report
as a result he concluded that the report
was not essential to the business and
could be eliminated
a similar reverse pilot can be carried
out in our social lives are there
commitments you routinely make to
customers colleagues friends or even
family members that you have always
assumed made a big difference to them
but that in fact they might barely
notice by quietly eliminating or at
least scaling back an activity for a few
days or weeks you might be able to
assess whether it is really making a
difference or whether no one really
cares even using these techniques it's
true that uncommitted can be harder than
simply not committing in the first place
we feel guilty saying no to something or
someone we have already committed to and
let's face it no one likes going back on
their word yet learning how to do so in
ways that will garner you respect for
your courage focus and discipline is
crucial to becoming an essentialist hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma deck you might remember 4 sig
Matic for their mushroom coffee
was created by those clever Finnish
founders and when I first mentioned that
coffee on this podcast the products sold
out in less than a week it lights you up
like a Christmas tree which can be
really useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
it still isn't easy very often and I
found reishi which have been fascinated
by for a few years now has been very
very effective and calming their old
formula however for sig Maddox old
formula included stevia and I like to
avoid sweeteners all sweeteners for a
host of reasons and I then just ping
them and asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it too much of a headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here are some
recommended copy that they put in the
read so I'm gonna read it and I'll give
you my take quote a warning for those in
the experimental mindset reishi is
strong and bitter in parentheses like
any great medicine so if the bitterness
is too much I recommend trying it with
honey and or nut milk such as almond
milk and put so I'm gonna say no you
should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter and
maybe should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
youngins when they say who and I'm sugar
cool which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication
things that help liver detoxification
and so on not saying that's the case
here but I've tested this reishi lecture
on family members on friends everybody
has liked it it's a little bit earthy
it's not that hard so I would just say
suck it up and know don't put in honey
or a nut milk or any of this [ __ ] just
drink the goddamn tea it's delicious I
think if you like puer that kind of
stuff that type of tea you're gonna dig
it so just try it okay back to then my
read if you'd like to naturally improve
your sleep
both onset and quality I think naturally
you might just enjoy this ratio lecture
without any sweeteners it has organic
reishi extract organic fueled mint
extract organic rosehips extract organic
Tulsi extract and that's it no fancy
stuff no artificial whatchamacallit
anything so check it out go to for Sigma
techcom ford slash ferrous and get 20%
off this special batch I don't know if
they're gonna be making much more of
this since it was made specifically for
you guys so do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for sig Matic that's fo you are SI GMA t
IC comm /e ferrous fe RR ISS and get 20%
off this special batch and you must use
the code
Ferris to receive a discount fer our ISS
so again go to for Sigma tech comm
forward slash Ferris and then use code
of Ferris for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
you
you